hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
uh no actually i'm sorry this is history
of science and technology q a
um
and uh
happy to talk about
things that i've been involved in or
other things i might know about and i
see a few questions here that have been
sent in or saved up
uh
well there's one from sleepyhead why did
electromagnetism become a focus of
studies so late in human civilization
wouldn't the ancients have observed and
studied magnets and started electricity
and characterized it as easily as us
it's an interesting question i mean a
lot of things don't get studied until
there's a certain
ambient
kind of set of understandings that make
it possible to sort of meaningfully
study something so for example what
would the ancients have known they would
have seen lightning they didn't know
what lightning was i mean in you know
greek mythology it was all about zeus
and thunderbolts and things like this
they knew lightning was a powerful thing
but i don't think they had any idea what
it was i don't know whether aristotle
wrote about lightning he you know tended
to try to catalog information about lots
of kinds of things
um but i think that they for them
lightning was sort of a thing of the
gods
and not something that us humans
would sort of be able to deal with so to
speak
i think uh people certainly had seen
lodestone
um
which um and and had seen uh magnetic
materials
i think that
where would they have seen magnetic
materials well i mean any kind of
they would have
they certainly would have seen static
electricity
um i'm not sure that anybody cared about
static electricity i'm not sure anybody
you know you rub your hand on some sheep
you know skin something or other and
then it starts making sparks and so on
it'd be an interesting question whether
any writers in antiquity commented on
that i'm not sure that they did
i mean i think that
it is an interesting thing that there
are things that one observes in the
world that people just say oh it is that
way we don't know why and we don't care
um
i think
you see that an awful lot in the history
of science
that
something isn't cared about until its
time is as has arrived i mean in my own
efforts to understand how
simple rules produce complicated
behavior and things like cellular
automata where you have a a line of
cells each let's say black or white and
you have some rule that says how to
color the cell on the line below based
on the color of the cell above it into
its left and right it's a very
straightforward setup and you know i've
always thought
somebody in babylonian times when they
started making mosaics that were made
from square arrays of
of stones could perfectly well have
studied cellular automata so far as i
know they didn't nobody's ever found a
mosaic that looks like that
um but i don't know why
and i don't really know what aspect of
it would have
uh you know what is the thing that makes
people not study that
so a good example that i have looked at
is nested patterns
where you have you know a pattern and
then other things nested inside it and
then that keeps going and there's sort
of a question of where did that first
get used
and i think it had a few origins but i
think the the most striking origin was
from a family of mosaic layers who lived
around 1200 a.d um mostly in italy
although they did work as far away as
westminster abbey and london and other
kinds of places um and
they
they figured out that you could make
these nested patterns or at least a
particular person cosmos cosmetic in
like 12 10 to 12 15 something around
that time
uh i wonder if they knew fibonacci who
lived in in italy around the exact same
time
um uh they'd be interesting to know i i
don't know i mean i don't know whether
the i think the world of the stonemason
artisan type crowd uh surely intersected
with the the mathematics and commercial
mathematics crowd which is what
fibonacci leonardo fibonacci was was uh
involved with
um but uh uh and you know that would be
a
you know it's an interesting thing i
mean what would why didn't somebody
notice oh they're these phylotaxis
spirals that are these particular sort
of arrangements in um
uh
of that are very generic implants
um where sort of the sequence of numbers
that you get out is a fibonacci sequence
and then fibonacci had its rabbits from
12 10 a.d or so and these people were
doing their mosaic tiles where they
discovered
nested patterns
and
but and in fact there's a there's a
church in in italy in agni italy where
you can see and there's the script where
they well you can kind of see that they
were sort of
experimenting with different kinds of
timing patterns and eventually they
figure out the nested pattern and
because it's it's some
uh sort of set in stone so to speak
because these wasn't mosaics it's still
there 800 years later and you can see
kind of the experiments that they did
but
this idea of nested patterns
rises in 1200 a.d it then disappears
for close to 800 years
until pretty much the early 1900s and
then
in the 1970s through the work of benoit
mangelbrot it becomes much more
prominent and fractals and then
everybody kind of knows to talk about
nesting patterns but before that time
you know the art historians writing
about the cosmetic they discuss you know
the the lions and tigers that they
portray in their mosaics and the
different ways they had to generate
color in their stones but no mention of
nested patterns they're just blind to
that but it's just something that there
isn't a sort of ambient understanding of
that people are primed to and i'd rather
suspect that something like static
electricity
uh even something like uh magnetism
um
let's see gilbert i guess was the person
who one was that 1600s maybe
uh really started talking about
magnetism and magnetism of the earth and
the fact that you could have magnetic
compasses and things like this
um but uh and
you know why didn't that happen earlier
some of those kinds of things were
technologically determined um you know
for example i don't know whether making
a compass that has a little magnetic
needle that can turn around i don't know
whether people had kind of bearings that
were good enough
to um you know or had figured out you
could kind of like just like have that
sort of sit on something where it could
turn easily enough that it could
actually turn
in in response to the earth's magnetic
field i mean that's why for example
in the time of aristotle
when there was a sort of the question of
what were the laws of motion for things
for aristotle most things when you push
them wouldn't keep moving unless you
kept on pushing them whereas by the time
of newton it became a little bit clearer
that a newton understood the
idealization
that you could push something and if it
wasn't then that there was actually a
that it was sort of a separate add-on
kind of concept that there was friction
that slowed the thing down and that
without friction that there was a
reasonable that the core
phenomenon was the thing just keeps
going in a straight line
newton's first law um and uh um and that
that wasn't something where friction was
somehow intrinsic to the nature of
things
probably was helped by by galileo and so
on noticing you know talking a lot about
things falling and again when things
sort of fall through the air
and you have you know the you drop a
feather in a rock well you know the
feather lands a long time after the rock
in the earth's atmosphere and so again
you could say well it's not
intrinsically the case that feathers and
rocks fall at the same rate it requires
kind of a conceptual idealization to
realize that's the case i mean
eventually when was it apollo 14 or
something
astronaut there dropped a feather and a
rock on the moon and observed that you
know in the vacuum of the moon they
really do drop at the same with the same
acceleration and and uh uh hit the
ground at the same time um and uh
something much assumed in the actual
celestial mechanics of getting
spacecraft after the movement but any
case so i i think this this question of
of what
causes people to
sort of uh conceptualize phenomenon
to the point where they can discuss them
now you know let's talk about
electricity
um
the uh
um
the first
i mean
electricity in you know the first
experiments who was at volto i guess
um was doing experiments with frog's
legs
rather boost an experiment where you are
sort of you know with electricity
you're giving a shock to the frog's leg
in the frog's leg jumps
because as we now know uh there's an
electrochemical process in muscles that
causes muscle contraction to happen in
that case
but in a sense what is the essential
phenomenon has nothing to do with frogs
nothing to do with muscles
it is an intrinsic thing to do with this
phenomenon of electricity which is an
abstraction far away from frogs and
muscles and so on and that you know
understanding how to pull away that
abstraction is not so obvious
just like you know you see a lightning
bolt
what is it
you know is it electricity even i don't
know when that was figured out but
that's that it was electricity um i
think
that um
the whole question of uh
kind of um the notion of electric
currents and batteries
and um all those kinds of things i mean
that was a a story
i think of of um
well that was the story of the 1800s but
it wasn't a story i mean the the
the um
uh
the kind of
really
electricity is an important thing rather
than just like oh that's an amusing
phenomenon that you can make sort of toy
things out of
that wasn't understood
until i would say
solidly into the 1800s i mean there's a
famous quote from
gladstone british prime minister talking
to faraday probably this must have been
1840s maybe
1850s perhaps
um
when
uh and uh you know faraday
who was some uh
a um
a very experimentally oriented scientist
who developed
some very abstract theories like the
idea of fields for example was a faraday
idea um but uh you know famously
gladstone asked faraday who was talking
about yesterday you know what's the good
of electricity and faraday talked about
well you know it's like a newborn baby
and you know it could has many
potentialities
and gladstone kind of just stopped and
said well what i really want to know is
can we tax it
um since that's sort of
a long time business of politicians so
to speak
the um uh um and i think you know that
kind of gives an indication that that
time electricity was still kind of a toy
phenomenon it was only uh much later
with with uh people like edison and so
on figuring out um
you know that you could use it for
electric blight
and and so on that it became clear that
it was sort of a a big thing worth
talking about
so
you know good question what and i don't
know how much uh sort of study
of electricity before
i mean it's sort of an interesting thing
that
uh how they think about it the things
like maxwell's equations
that describe
um
uh
the electromagnetic field and and
faraday's previous work characterizing
the ultra magnetic field and doing
things with iron filings showing the you
know the directions of magnetic flux and
so on that those predated
uh the sort of the practical use of
electricity for things
um
and uh
uh
so yeah i mean i think
it's some it's sort of a cautionary tale
perhaps of phenomena that we see today
where we say that's just a toy
phenomenon and then later on we realized
well actually it's a phenomenon that has
uh deep practical significance
um and i think that's a that's a
repeated story in the history of science
that something that seemed like it was
just a
a
almost a toy and there were things where
there were phenomena
uh like automata for example uh you know
mechanical automata that do things and
you know it's a duck that walks and
plaques and so on there were many toys
of that kind from certainly the 1600s
and so on uh there were many such toys
long before the sort of use of clockwork
things for more than clocks
was was a common kind of a concept
and i think
in
uh in my own work this whole phenomenon
of simple rules complicated behavior
there are a zillion examples
of where that was observed
but thought to be irrelevant
was thought that it was just like oh you
know we're making an artificial neural
net
and it's a nuisance that in certain
domains this artificial neural net
starts generating all this kind of
quotes noise and randomness because what
we really want is the domain where it
does something different and so that
phenomenon which was sort of a very
important phenomenon
was not really talked about you know i
just realized literally yesterday
something about some uh piece of my own
history in a sense
um it's fascinating thing
to me at least
uh you know sort of how one pieces
history together
there are lots of specific sort of dots
and the question is can you join the
dots into a meaningful narrative and
particularly when the history is about
things one's done oneself
it's often very confusing because
you know the dots you know the specific
things that happened
but on the ground when they were
happening you were not thinking about
the overall narrative it's only maybe
decades later you can look back and see
the narrative that joins those dots and
i was just doing a big exercise um just
posted something about the making of my
new kind of science book where i did a
lot of kind of looking in archives i had
pretty good personal archives um and
trying to piece together what had
happened and some of that the arc of
that story
is
i only remember the points i never
figured out the arc of the story and how
things happen but i'll tell you an arc
of story which i i just figured out it's
sort of embarrassing i didn't know this
before
so in the 1980s i started working on
cellular automata and how simple rules
could produce complicated behavior now i
had previously worked a lot in
traditional theoretical physics
and
i
so i started off studying simple rules
like in cellular automata
and
the immediate thing i would have
expected is oh i've got all these fancy
mathematical methods and so on given
these simple rules i can just figure out
what they do i can use all these
mathematical methods to come up with an
analysis of what's going on
okay well that didn't work
now meanwhile at that time early to
midnight early to mid 1980s i got a
number of very
distinguished mathematicians for example
interested in these problems of what do
these simple systems do
they worked on them and they were very
frustrated because they could get
practically no
methods that they knew just didn't make
any progress methods that i knew didn't
make any progress either
what i realized
now long after the fact is
the sort of in a sense the key
achievement that i had was not just to
block at that point not just to say look
you know these systems the methods i
know don't do anything oh let me look at
those aspects of these systems where the
methods i know do do something instead i
kind of turned that situation on its
head and said look the fact that we
blocked that in itself is significant
and that was what caused me to discover
computational irreducibility which has
been sort of a cornerstone of many kinds
of things that have been figured out
since and now you know it i think led to
things like the proof of work idea for
blockchain and all kinds of unexpected
consequences but the um the fact that in
that situation
where one was kind of had a particular
methodology one could have just blocked
and said we're done there's nothing to
say here let's go look in another corner
where we can say something about the
system but instead it's like you know to
the big achievement in a sense was to
think to turn that situation on its head
and say the very fact that we blocked
the very fact that we got this great
complexity from this simple set of rules
was the important thing and then build
what i ended up in the title of the book
that that came out 20 years ago now you
know called a new kind of science so to
speak
anyway a few thoughts on on that
okay there's a question here from brady
why did touring come up with turing
machines as a basis for computation and
not tag or substitution systems or
mobile automator or register machines
well
i think
uh
at the time
most computing
was done in places like banks
most of the let's
work something out the most sort of
industrial place where things were
computed was things like banks maybe
insurance companies and so on as well
and
what alan turing was trying to do i
think
was to make an idealized model
of how bank clerks worked
and bank clerks would have certain you
know they'd have certain data that's in
a file cabinet and they would go and
they would take something out of the
file cabinet they would do a computation
on it they would put the result back in
the file cabinet and that's kind of the
thing that he was modeling in a turing
machine where you have a tape that has
certain data on it and you have his head
that's going up and down the tape
now interesting question why did
alan turing have the concept of a tape
and
it's an interesting question whether
telex machines existed
i don't know i don't think they did um
okay so a little bit of history here um
so a very early invention was the the
punch card was invented around 1800 by
um
marija khan
um to make the jacquard loom
um which was a uh a um
a weaving machine
that um
uh was controlled by where you could
specify the pattern
for weaving
by uh using this punch card um and there
was a mechanical device that would um uh
would would be based on that and that's
what for example babbage's concept for
the analytical engine
um was based on using jacquard type
punch cards um
to program the engine that was thought
about in the 1830s and so on um
interestingly i know
uh you know ada lovelace has this lovely
uh paragraph where she talks about some
the analytical engine
weaves algebraical patterns
as the jacquard loom
weaves patterns of birds and flowers
um
because it's sort of using the same
technology for specifying sort of what
to do
and i i know that um ada lovelace for
example
went on tour when she was uh
late-ish teenager once on a tour with
her mother
of um the uh of the mills in northern
england this is the time of the
industrial revolution and um there the
mills
are um uh i have these looms and um uh
so she got to see a bunch of these sort
of punch cards in operation that was
that was uh a decade before
um she ended up writing about babbage's
analytical engine and trying to sort of
abstract away from the engineering
details of the analytical engine but
that was kind of the first model for
computation was the analytical engine
and this notion of sort of the punch
card as the way of deciding what
um algebraical operations
to use
ada's kind of term for it
would be done so that
that whole story kind of more or less
disappeared for a very very long time
and the environment that turing was
working in
i can tell a little bit of that history
but i think touring
um
really his
his thing was to model
uh bank club so i was going to say about
about um
uh
tapes
i don't know where turin got the tape
idea from
there certainly was a technology of
paper tape
that was used for telex machines
and it's a really good question when
telex machines came into existence
um because what they were
were kind of
in a sense automated telegraphs
you know the which
uh just by the time i knew about them
were using phone lines
um
the uh um
um
in um
um
uh
to to transmit data so for example when
i was a kid
um
i
would see um
uh my father ran a company that that uh
did import export kinds of things
from different countries around the
world um good thing if you're a kid and
do stamp collecting or something but um
uh the you know a big part of their
business was you know sending messages
all over the place and so they had telex
machines
and this was this must have been well
mid-1960s
um but i think they were well developed
technologies so i'm i'm guessing they've
been around for at least 30 years and
probably since since the time of of
touring
and the 19 in that turing machines were
1936.
um
so
the uh
what did a telex machine do
it had a paper tape that you would
prepare offline and you would you know
you would you would prepare it and you
would make this punch tape um
and uh
the um
uh this and then this tape
would be then you would connect your
your phone line to the place where you
were sending the the message
and uh you would and the tape would get
run through and the tape would specify
it was usually fired hole tape that
would specify uh different characters
much like a telegram they were usually
sort of all capital letter characters um
the uh um and uh and you would sort of
minimize the time where your phone line
had to be open um by uh
um by the fact that you prepared it on
this paper tape
so um
uh
oh yes okay various people are pointing
out all right telex became a thing in
1933 apparently oh yes pontius mentions
ticker tape yeah that that's that's
right that was that was edison's first
invention right was um
this idea
i'm not sure about all of this
technology i mean the the um
uh
four
stock markets
there was this notion of
uh recording the trades
and i think edison invented a um
uh sort of remote ticker tape machine
which i i think was based on
a
telegraph and the telegraph comes from
the
1830s maybe samuel morse and so on um
and uh i mean the the that was a
um an early electrical machine so to
speak the telegraph
um
okay so so i don't know whether you know
so i guess this idea of information
being stored on a tape was a little bit
of a thing by turing's time although
those tapes were definitely right once
tapes
like a telex machine tape you just you
write it once and then you send it
through the machine um
but uh so i suppose that idea of a tape
may have come from those kinds of places
now you know the tradition into which
touring was was was operating
um
the
um
uh okay david is saying here that the
ticker tape stock price telegraphs were
invented in 1867 by certain edward
callahan an 18t employee
that sounds
implausible when did att that was a jp
morgan
enterprise to to pull together what
became
att i think from a lot of regional phone
companies i mean it's kind of like the
same thing that happens in many
industries that there are first of all
very geographically distributed happen
with the internet happen with uh you
know happen with um uh internet
connectivity and other kinds of things
um that you know first there are lots of
regional uh sort of deliver
you know providers of those kinds of
things and then it all gets kind of
centralized because of economies of
scale
but um uh any case i you know to say
something about the tradition that
turing operated in
this whole question of sort of
how do you make
what how do you mechanize mathematics a
mechanized not in the sense of having a
machine do it but in the sense of
streamline the way that humans would
specify it
and i think
that
idea you know for example fraga got rob
fraga
in the
1860s 70s
uh was very much interested in this kind
of you know could you derive mathematics
from logic and in so doing sort of build
a tower that would be um
would kind of streamline the the
specification of mathematics now that
became more serious
with people like piano in the 1880s
who um
really tried to sort of write down
uh
in in a in a streamlined mechanical way
what mathematics might be like and write
down a streamlined set of axioms in his
case with piano particularly
concentrated on the accidents of
arithmetic and so on i mean to explain a
little bit you know the idea
that it really mattered to do
mathematics in a systematic way as
opposed to just well you know we can see
that it's true so that's good enough
i mean there was a tradition of that
kind of thing all the way back from
euclid for geometry it became more of a
thing in other areas of mathematics by
the 1830s and so on where people were
starting to invent kind of purely formal
structures like group theory like
plutonians um like uh
um
the notion of curved space and so on
these were things that were
uh sort of purely abstract constructs
where you kind of didn't have an
intuitive sense of how things would come
out so you really had to build
everything from this sort of formal
axioms but piano i think produced this
little book
um
about uh sort of axiomatic mathematics
um he was a very kind of let's make
everything axiomatic including human
language so he invented a thing called
interlingua there was another thing by
the same name later um that was a kind
of latin based language that was his
kind of attempt at a formal human
language as well as writing down his
mathematics formally but i think then
you know david hilbert and then bertrand
russell
were in their different ways
instrumental in this idea of let's
streamline sort of how you write down
mathematics
now then
you know 1920
uh sort of two big initiatives well 1921
emil post
kind of tries to say well how can you i
should explain 1910
uh whitehead and russell produced that
principia mathematica this two-volume
work which was an attempt to kind of
show that you could derive all of
mathematics from logic and it uses
absolutely grotesque notation and it's
very hard to understand and i consider
it largely a show-off exercise
i'm not sure that um i think russell was
proud of the fact that nobody had really
you know only five people had ever read
it or whatever he said
um and it it proudly goes through you
know i don't know what some uh 100 pages
of text before it manages to prove that
one plus one equals two
and you know it has a lot of notational
problems like for example it uses dots
instead of parentheses so you don't get
the kind of match fixing of parentheses
and that's that's a big big big nuisance
then it also makes the mistake
that was repeated with for example apl
as a computer language that it just has
too much
notation that nobody knows
and so it has at the back it has this
huge long list of all these different
kinds of notations
and you know people just don't have that
bigger notation buffer this is something
that as a designer of computational
languages i've been very interested in
and basically the fact that we are able
to build computational language is a
consequence the fact that we can
leverage human language we can have
wolfram language functions that are
whose names are based on english words
if we had 7 000 things that were all
hieroglyphic symbols it would be
absolutely hopeless nobody would ever be
able to learn it but we can leverage the
existing learning that people have of
human natural language to to be able to
provide them something which is is also
a computational language and whitehead
and russell
didn't didn't block that
and instead
they chose to invent very pure notation
um in sort of an imitation of
mathematical notation that it existed
for a few hundred years by then but they
didn't realize that if you if you bring
it on in boatloads people just lose it
uh i suppose as a practical matter i
know that um
uh cambridge university press
published the principia mathematica
books and there were a lot of you know
exotic notations there
and um uh it said uh somebody actually
from cambridge university press told me
this story years ago
that um uh
the press really objected to all of this
weird notation like how we're going to
typeset this they were using lead type
so they were using um you know actually
putting the symbols in there and they
had fonts that were you know letters of
the alphabet and they had some greek
fonts and things like this but when it
came to exotic symbols they just didn't
have that type
and so uh so russell agreed to pay for
the um uh
making the actual pieces of lead that
would be the characters that would be
printed in the book for his exotic
notation and according to
my informant from cambridge university
press
who um uh russell was to be seen in the
streets of cambridge with a wheelbarrow
wheeling the lead type to the press to
be used in in the precipitation
mathematica books
um now you know
uh
it wasn't a very good idea but um those
books were very famous in their time and
really led there were really two
traditions there was the david hilbert
tradition and there was the russell
whitehead tradition but that really was
the thing that everybody was responding
to
um i mean by uh you know girdle was
responding to principia mathematica in
its original paper um turing in his
original paper
which is
on computable numbers and the insidents
problem the insurance problem is a
decision problem that was invented by
hilbert
and
that was kind of the problem of if you
can write something down notationally in
mathematical logic or in sort of
streamlined mathematics if you can write
it down notationally can you determine
because that does that mean you can
determine it's true or false
and so in other words is the pure
writing down of something uh sort of is
that what you really need and then you
can always solve it and what turing was
arguing is no you can't what durdle was
arguing was that principia mathematica
had a similar kind of problem they'd
come from slightly different notational
foundations but it was the same idea but
anyway post 1921
um he was really taking protipia
mathematica
and trying to sort of idealize that and
saying all these things that they're
doing with all this crazy notation and
etc etc etc how do we represent that in
a more streamlined way and he came up
with string substitution systems
and uh that was the basis for his uh
well his tag systems were even an
idealization of that a simplification of
what you need to do you don't have to
replace things anywhere in a string you
can just do it at the front of the
string and stick the replacement on the
back of the string and keep cycling
around that was 1921 and you know post
had this period of time where he said if
only i can solve the problem of tag and
the problem of of what happens with an
arbitration substitution system then i
will have solved mathematics then i
would have completed the hilbert program
of being able to solve this decision
problem and other kinds of things once
you write down the notation it's just a
question of grinding it and you can get
the answer
and post in 1921 uh realized oops the
problem of tag is much harder than i
thought you know i looked at this again
last year actually and tried to finally
solve the problem that posts had had and
even with all of today's methods and
computers and so on you know i forget i
must have run it for hundreds of
billions trillions of steps
i still don't know what it does
um
and um uh so you know post
uh that was the thing that post backed
into now
it's an interesting thing in terms of
history of science post
sort of understood that that was an
important thing he didn't push it all
the way and so godel
who pushed it further pushed the same
kinds of ideas further came from a
different place and post always said uh
you know by the 1940s he was saying that
you know
as he said to godel
um post said i would have discovered
girdle's theorem if i had been girdle
um and post was very close to girls
theorem into computational
irreducibility in 1921 but didn't really
have the the conceptual framework for it
now
meanwhile moses sean finkel in 1920
invented combinators
uh
where those come from
and
uh is you know i did a very big
historical study of this in in the
centenary moment of combinations in
december of 19 of december 2020
um
and i can say that one really doesn't
know where these ideas came from uh the
conceptualization the the the ideas
sean finkel was sort of in the hilbert
orbit inverting and
um
and uh
the
the sort of one of the originating ideas
was this fact that the nand operation uh
the the not and
logical operation
can be put together to make and an or
not an xor and all the kinds of possible
logic operations and that was a fact
that was discovered around 1900 uh
really by at least three different
people um one of them was henry scheffer
who was a professor at harvard um he
actually came from as as a as an amazing
number of the logicians of that time and
maybe even now uh came from uh kind of
the ukraine poland type area of the
world so did henry schaffer um although
that was uh he was very americanized i
think he came to the u.s when he was
a young child
um but he was a professor at harvard he
was discovering this meanwhile uh
somewhat mysteriously to me and i
haven't tracked down this history
um uh charles sanders purse
who was also in the boston harvard type
orbit his father had been a professor
at harvard um
uh was um charles sanders pierce himself
i think was kind of more of a um
i don't know what he'd call him a
gentleman scientist or a not a
professional scientist i think was uh i
think he worked for the u.s coast guard
um but he produced a lot of
philosophical works
um they're not so easy to understand but
he was another person who at the more or
less the same time discovered this
universality this functional
completeness of the nand operation i
think sean finkel was trying to follow
kind of the notation of logic um but do
it for
for as he realized actually with some
clarity for general mathematics and
general computation but that kind of
that that lead went cold because uh sean
finkel himself kind of disappeared
and um
uh well
um
haskell curry who kind of took up the
torch of combinators
didn't really think of them in the same
kind of way i think
for at least for quite a long time
so so that so touring didn't really have
a um
uh
uh
touring was kind of operating in a
in a sort of independent way
um and uh in in thinking about turing
machines um i have to say i think
probably
had
posts work become better known i suspect
that would have been the most natural
way for people to think about um the
sort of foundations of computation i
think turing machines are not you know i
i would say that they are if anything
they're harder to program than string
substitution systems um and i think
that's sort of an accident of history
that it went that way now register
machines are much later construct i mean
they really come after long after as a
theoretical idealization they come long
after
the um uh the actual practicalities of
electronic computers that had registers
places to store numbers and so on i i
believe uh shepherdson and sturgis were
the people i believe even in the
gosh was it 1960 something like that
that register machines were sort of
introduced as a as a well this is
another model of computation
um i think cellular automata had
predated them as another model of
computation um they are uh
they were
you know their equivalence to turing
machines was well known
in the 1950s and so on um and uh
uh so i think that that um uh you know
that that's another piece there
um
let's see
the um
uh parmesan's commenting the joke was
that girdle was the only person who'd
read um uh i think must be referring to
vocabulary mathematica um
you know i'm um
uh i'm trying to remember
yes the um when i was researching sean
finkel
um
there
are some
people
i think haskell curry had read it
because i think there's a um
a piece of mail from russell
thanking haskell curry if i'm not
mistaken
for
typos
in
the second edition of principal
mathematica
um and there's a
this the acknowledgements in particular
mathematica um are sort of interesting
because they do list a number of people
there
um
let's see
there's a comment from philip
uh about einstein came to regret the
name theory of relativity would theory
of invariance have been a better choice
oh you know naming of things is so hard
because i mean i i can say in my own
life
uh for example the name mathematica for
our
uh
uh
sort of flagship product
is good in its time and bad
you know in a later you know in
later you know in that particular case
i named mathematica that
because
it's i knew perfectly well that its goal
was more general than mathematics
but i named it in 1987
and at that time two things were unknown
one the extent to which
the thing we were building
was we knew its big use case was people
who thought they were doing mathematical
kinds of things
but the big unknown that was a mistake
in retrospect is
that i didn't know how mathematics was
going to evolve
and the question was would the things
that i would now call sort of the
computational paradigm be claimed by
mathematics or not
the answer is not
the answer is that mathematics the way
it evolved it computer science very
firmly branched off from mathematics and
that had happened to some extent by the
mid-1980s but not nearly as firmly as
has happened today
i think that um uh i know sort of in the
more ancient history of of computer
science i mean you have to realize in
the mid 1980s
not every major university in the us had
a computer science department yet
um i remember for example princeton when
i was at the institute for advanced
study princeton did not yet have a
computer science department they had
electrical engineering department they
had other things but they didn't have a
sort of fully uh sort of separated from
the science department i don't think
harvard did either i think it was part
of the division of applied science
um so you know at that time it was still
not a fully fledged you know flying on
its own
uh type of field
and you know it was an interesting
question whether
whether
what the sort of interweaving of
mathematics and computer science would
be and to what extent uh it would sort
of break off as its own quite separate
field i know that um
uh
when i was at the institute for advanced
study in princeton the um the people who
had been there for the von neumann
computer project
a few of them were still there
and um i remember an interesting event
where some people particularly herman
goldstein who was um one of the people
who worked with von neumann who ended up
going to ibm which is where a lot of the
kind of know-how from the von neumann
computer project ended up landing up um
coming back to the institute and giving
a talk about sort of the history of
computing at the institute and so on
this must have been
oh when was it
1983-4 something like that
um there's a person called julian
bigelow who'd been an early engineer
working on the computer project who was
still sort of around
at um at the institute at that time
anyway there were a whole bunch of
people
and there were also people like andre
bay mathematician
um and uh
some other people like that who were
kind of in the older generation of
mathematicians at the institute and i
remember i think i asked the question
and um to this sort of assembled group i
kind of asked the the the mathematicians
you know what did you foresee about what
would happen to computing back in in the
1950s you know von neumann died in
1956 i think um i'm 57 maybe um and uh
uh you know what did you think was going
to happen with computers
and um
uh for some reason
yeah i think i think my own experience
had been
that there were mathematicians at the
time
and this is um
uh yeah that's right that's right i have
been doing a certain amount of
experimental mathematics and there were
a bunch of mathematicians who said
uh some some how they wrote this
somewhere i don't remember quite where
but um uh
in criticism of my work actually
computers will never be relevant for the
doing of mathematics
that's that was
probably
early 1980s and i should get a um
a more concrete reference for that but
so so in the air was the concept that
mathematics was a thing and computers
were never going to be relevant to doing
mathematics that have been in previous
generation mathematicians and i remember
kind of throwing that question out to
this group
and there was quite a really heated
discussion about um you know the
mathematicians saying no no of course we
understood back in the 1950s that you
know computers would be important for
something just wasn't for the
mathematics that we cared about
and um the uh the people who've been
working on the computer project saying
no no you know you were trying to you
know you were trying to get us out of
the building and you know you know get
the whole thing away from here it's it's
all just a bad idea so to speak so
this whole interaction between you know
mathematics computer science
uh would computer science would even
theoretical computer science be a part
of mathematics or would it be its own
thing was something still very much in
the air and so in the naming of
something like mathematica um it was
kind of a little bit of a a calculation
of whether the the mathematics would
expand in its domain and in fact if
anything it's contracted a bit in its
domain um whereas the whole sort of
computational paradigm was greatly
expanded so it remains a a challenge now
as we talk about wolverine language and
so on and as we're trying to sort of
describe the whole system that we built
for executing computational language
it's one of my uh
long time projects to try and um uh come
up with the right description and name
for that thing and it's difficult to do
because a thing like it doesn't
otherwise exist and so it's not a thing
where you can say well i'm gonna give it
that name and everybody knows what that
name means because many other things are
named like that
so i think in terms of of um
the theory of relativity i don't know
what the ambient
uh notion of sort of relativism
in particular the social sciences uh how
prevalent i mean that was a thing that
was sort of bubbling at the same ish
time
as the theory of as einstein's theory of
relativity and i don't know to what
extent the um i mean i think some of
that predated einstein's use of the term
relativity and i think maybe he was
sort of trying to uh uh kind of juice it
up by using a term that was kind of in
the air at the time
i mean it's it's the same type of thing
i suppose
um interesting sort of case because
when i talk about you know what does
simple rules what consequences the
simple rules have when i was talking
about that 20 30 years ago
i would always say
rules like programs like computer
programs i would talk about simple
computer programs because if i talk
about rules as a disembodied abstract
thing that's not something people should
be familiar with it but they're not the
kind of rules people can imagine being
repeatedly applied and so on those are
in programs and so that ends up being
a um uh you know that's the metaphor
that's the ambient description is it's
all about programs so to speak even
though at some level the abstract
concept has nothing to do with programs
the abstract concept is just about
formal rules and i don't know to what
extent einstein
was
influenced by kind of the ambient
notions of you know this is a little bit
like what people are talking about in
social science and that will maybe help
people understand it will kind of juice
it up make it seem more relevant etc i
mean i i think that
it would have been a mistake to call it
theory of invariance because um
uh at the time there was an awful lot of
stuff that was talking about invariants
um i mean in in the whole uh for example
um
uh quadratic forms which hermann
mikowski you know the person who
sort of really really got big on the t
squared minus x squared version of of
you know invariant intervals and so on
um that was
invariant forms were a big thing in the
late 1800s um as the sort of theory of
uh
oh gosh
i that that whole set of theories i mean
determinant theory was a big branch of
mathematics and
oh my gosh what were those things called
um there's a lot of stuff to do with
sort of the algebra
of systems of polynomials and so on that
was really a a sort of
a primary area
in in mathematics at that time and that
was a lot of that was around invariant
theory and and the idea and variance and
so on so i think that would have been
even more confusing because it was it
was kind of a a story that was a story
of of things like the squadratic form
that meant gossipy kind of injected into
relativity theory so i i'm not sure that
um um
i'm not sure it would have been a good
name i mean it's hard to know
sort of so long after the fact some of
these things become sort of just uh you
know they are evocative in their time
like the tape of a touring machine might
have been evocative in its time today
i'm sure
modern
students learning theoretical computer
science
there's this discussion about a tape and
they're like what on earth is a tape
doing i mean the only thing i know about
is scotch tape or duct tape or something
like that what what do you mean tape
because people are not even familiar
with magnetic tape now
of a thing where you're reading writing
things going back and forth
um
actually that's another interesting
question
no i think
magnetic tape
post-dated turing machines by quite a
long way
uh yeah yeah because i think at the time
that's right people were recording
things
um for example one of the things i've
tried to track down
is um
uh
the um
um
uh alan turing gave a radio talk in 1950
on artificial intelligence and i've just
been really curious to hear his voice
and so i'm just curious did anybody
record that
and i was was interested in you know
well i mean in today's world like
everything will be recorded everything's
you know and people are playing things
on the radio from tape
um or from you know from now from
digital kinds of sources so i was
actually a little while ago i was
happened to be at the science museum in
london looking around at some exhibits
actually with a friend of mine who for a
long time worked for the bbc
and um actually also happens my friend
happens to be an expert on the history
of sound recording
and um so i was asking him so so why
didn't the bbc have recordings of stuff
from 1950 and so and he was explaining
that um
the you know the process of recording
something was pretty expensive you know
you would essentially cut a phonograph
record more or less to record the thing
and that was something that you know who
would do that it was much cheaper to
just bring the talent into the studio so
to speak and have them give a radio talk
in real time and why would anybody
record it there was no reason to do that
i mean when i was a kid for example they
recorded stuff that you would find of
that type things like the speaking clock
for example that you could you know call
a phone number i wonder if this still
exists you would call a phone number and
it would tell you the time and that was
a you know that was sort of a phonograph
recordy type thing i think that was
being um
was being used to produce that
technology
um
let's see
uh
yeah philip comments that ironic that
the bertrand russell had a very clear
prose style and was also responsible for
the most unreadable books so it is an
interesting point isn't it
i mean i think the thing that
is perhaps unfair
about some of that is that
uh
i don't know maybe it's the
former perhaps british education system
but there were awful lot of people i
mean even even in my own case i mean i
don't know you can you can all decide
whether i'm a decent writer or not but
you know it
it somehow
uh
the somehow it was a product the british
education system
was
being able to write reasonable prose was
just an awfully common thing
i mean and it's sort of odd because a
lot of the british education system
actually didn't involve writing
english prose it involved ridiculous it
seemed to me at the time exercise as
well translated from latin to english
okay translating from english into latin
verse it's like that's a really weird
exercise which it's not clear would help
you with much at all um it's a sort of
interesting puzzle type exercise but for
some for some reason uh certain people
who have gone through the british
education system at least back in the
past i can't speak to today it seems to
be sort of the reasonable writing comes
for free
you know i'd like to think that in
modern times reasonable computational
writing in computational language that i
don't know like our summer schools and
summer camps and things maybe they
provide you know it will be nice to
think that they provide a sort of a a uh
reasonable writing and computational
language comes for free so to speak i
think that um so
i i think the notion
that um
uh
so you know that tradition of english
prose writing seems to be uh kind of a
thing i you know it is i will say that i
think um
that uh uh you know it's it's a it's a
super useful thing to learn
but you know what's sort of interesting
about it and a little bit paradoxical in
terms of what i'm saying
is that you know what i've noticed is
that most people who understand things
clearly can write them down clearly
that's at least a claim i i know maybe
the the opposite is true people who
don't understand things clearly cannot
write them down clearly so maybe there
are people actually now that i think
about it there are certainly people i
know who understand things clearly but
have never
learned to write particularly fluently
and so the stuff they write is very very
poorly constructed even though they can
explain things with with with good
clarity so i i perhaps i'm i'm um uh so
i i don't know how how teachable that is
i have never personally been a great fan
of bertrand russell um i
have to say that i haven't um
uh
probably readily wrote an awful lot of
books and i have read few of them um and
i'm perhaps influenced by principal
mathematica which i consider to be not a
very
i mean it was a it was a
it was a project
that was impressive for show
but
in detail just a mess in my opinion
um
the uh
so i can't um
i can't comment on those things and i
have to say in terms of of
philosophical works
i've
uh i don't know of sort of primary
philosophy that russell did
that has been significant at least in
the kinds of things i've been interested
in although i think potentially his
exposition of sort of ambient philosophy
was was good and clear
i mean it's worth realizing that um
alfred
north whitehead um
co-author the first author actually
principal mathematica was already a
pretty distinguished mathematician in
fact
whitehead's
previous works
uh his previous work i think from 1900
was a book called universal algebra
um which was a book about uh kind of the
how you can take the framework of
algebraic systems and generalize that
framework and it's it's um and that book
is quite good
and quite clear and in many ways much
less crazy but much less crazy than
principal mathematica i mean whitehead
went on to write a lot of books about
education and so on i have to say i've
not read most of those books um and
eventually ended up in the u.s
after a long career in england um i
haven't read his later works i can't
comment on them but um yeah it could be
that two clear writers came together to
produce an unreadable book in principle
mathematica i'm not sure
um
but uh um in any case the the um
you know this question about
mathematical notation i know that uh
that russell had met piano gossip piano
at 1900 at the international congress of
mathematicians the same one where
hilbert
um
enunciated his 23 problems for
mathematics
um
i think piano
has not fantastic notation but much
better much less over-the-top notation
than uh than whitehead and russell
um i mean i think piano
had um
had some notation for implication that
has been
not perfectly successful but but he had
he had a number of other notations which
have caught on
um i think that um
uh this this whole idea
of what will be understandable
kind of the art of designing notation
is an art that people
have only rarely understood so for
example leibniz in the 1600s was quite
into the art of designing notation
even though his own efforts like d by dx
for for derivatives you know he knew
right off the from the get-go that
people would try and cancel the d's
and but he thought well it's a it's a
cool notation it's got some cute
features let's go with it for the time
being as a sort of preliminary notation
i found the place actually where
where he first writes down the s the
elongated s that became the integral
sign and so on
but um uh you know people at different
times of an interesting notation george
boole in the 1830s pretty interesting
notation
um uh alan turing actually wrote an
unpublished piece on mathematical
notation
um he was interested in it
uh but he didn't there were things he he
understood and didn't understand one of
the things that i think
well von neumann certainly didn't
understand was the idea of of
subroutines the idea of sub functions in
a program
so this notion that we'll write a
program and it's a monolithic thing for
neumann imagine that would be the way
things worked and so he thought nobody
will ever write a program more than a
few hundred lines long
because well nobody will understand that
i don't know that was his logic but he
certainly said that that he didn't
expect long programs that were written
he didn't understand this idea of
modular programs and this idea of
sub-functions and so on it's surprising
in retrospect he didn't understand that
because clearly mathematical proofs rely
on other theorems other lemmas and so on
and have that kind of hierarchical
structure
but um when it comes to touring
it's some
uh touring
was in many ways a sort of
quintessential hacker
and um
he uh you know he had a lot of cute
hacks
i mean in addition to the touring
machine which one could argue with
something of a hack he'd
you know he invented a bunch of you know
mechanical things for computing the
riemann zeta function by using a thing
with cogs and so on and can find his
blueprints from that he i don't think it
was ever he ever actually built it
a good thing for somebody to make these
days i wonder if anybody has
um but uh
the um
uh you know i remember looking years ago
at uh touring's coding sheets from the
manchester computer
from um
1952-ish time frame i think and they're
unbelievably hacky i mean he had you
know among his
uh
moments of um
um
of whatever i mean he was writing in
well not in hex he had to write i think
in base 64. and he decided he'll take
the letters of the alphabet and then
it'll take semicolons and all these
different characters and you get this
absolutely unreadable sequence of of
characters that was some i think base64
maybe based 32 uh representative may i
think it was based 32 representation of
things
um and uh there was no notion of kind of
um
uh elegance
in uh
in programming at the time in the time
of touring i i don't know it'd be
interesting question who first really
grocked the idea of elegance and
programming i think the people who were
working on the algol specification in
1960 maybe had some inkling of that kind
of thing i'm not sure um because
certainly in the time of um
um
uh
in in you know so the the notion that
notation mattered and notation was an
art to produce good notation i think
that was something that was not really
well and so perhaps not even well
understood today i certainly know that
the design and the functional design of
programs is something that is not well
understood i mean it's something
language design for example is something
that i'm not sure
uh you know people really understand is
a thing
to me
language design computational language
design
is one of the purest
forms of sort of deep thinking that
there is around
it's a thing where what one is trying to
do is take all these different ideas and
crispen them you know turn find the
essence of those ideas and represent
them in a way that isn't just like
poetry sort of a right once this is the
form of the words type of thing but it's
something where you have to build kind
of a a a mechanism that can be used in a
in in an infinite collection of
different ways that is sort of an
elegant representation of the essence of
ideas and for me it's it's kind of the
the best representation of the essence
of ideas and it's something about which
i mean perhaps because i've spent 40
something years doing it um i think
there is a lot to know and it's quite an
art
uh sort of a combination of an art and
some kind of intellectual activity a
philosophy of science i'm not sure
um to figure out kind of what is the uh
you know how do you uh actually come up
with sort of this essential
representation of ideas um and you know
i as you may know i do lots of live
streams of my sort of uh front line
efforts
to design
our computational language welcome
language um and uh but i consider that a
a difficult thing
and i think that in the time of
whitehead and russell most likely they
just didn't think it was a thing they
just thought just throw in this notation
and you know it'll people will learn it
just like they've learned other
notations and it'll all just work
and they didn't really understand that
they were building some kind of art form
that needed to be done in a careful way
um
i think come
as a comment here from memes
about einstein that um at least you
didn't name it space-time stuff and
things
yeah i mean it is always interesting
when you read
you know
english language and you know obviously
einstein wrote in german
uh which i can't indigenously read um
but uh um sorry i can't really comment
on on his stylistic
uh character well he wrote later in
english um but um
um
you know it is always interesting when
you read
kind of uh i don't know newton's optics
was written in english newton's
principia was written in latin but he
transitioned by the time he wrote his
optics he transitioned to writing in
english and it is interesting the extent
to which
uh there's been evolution both in the
um in the english language and in the
mathematical language so for example
in those times i think people are still
writing x x x to represent x cubed
it wasn't common to have exponent
notation yet things like that um but
it's you know you see these things
that i it is always funny to see see
things where
uh there are
ways of describing things which sort of
seem natural at the time and later on
seem unbelievably ponderous like for
example a good example of this is
time dilation it wasn't called time
dilation back in the day it was called
time dilatation that was the original
you know if you look at early books in
english on relativity it's time
dilatation but somewhere
that got you know thought to be very
ponderous and it just turned into time
dilation and now when you see dilatation
it sounds like some weird uh you know
antique form and that's something that
one one sees happened quite quite
repeatedly i mean i think one of the
ones that is really a thing that um
uh
gets to one when one sees it
is the references to particularly well
ambient thinking ambient technology
um
uh
you know it's it's certainly i could be
a little bit cynical
and say that
some of the the things that perhaps age
most are the dedications to books
um
and uh you know
there were times when it was always
dedicated to you know the duke who is
allowing me to publish this or who's
sponsoring me
you know it's dedicated for the greater
glory of god
it's dedicated to
the funding agents they're not quite
dedicated to but it's kind of uh you
know uh it's it's it's acknowledging the
funding agency of the government x
it's um giving a thing that says you
know um
uh
this is being done to make the world a
better place and so on i think those
kind of motivational and um
uh acknowledgments kind of probably age
the most if you look at um uh at
scientific documents uh followed by you
know technological kinds of things where
there just are
are terms
that
over the course of 100 years we just
have no idea what they are you have to
go look up
um some things where
where people are talking about him and
one that just comes to mind is turing
talking about brunswigers which were a
brand of mechanical calculator of his
time
um which just completely unknown to us
today
but um you know i think that's a um
it's interesting that the names of like
mathematical theories and so on have
changed much less than the names of
these kind of technological kinds of
things
all right i should probably well maybe i
can take one
more uh
i better i think i'd better go to my
my next um
meeting here um although
lots of interesting questions here which
i'd love to
um address
um
but i think we have to leave that
uh for another time
so well
uh
thanks for joining me here today and um
i just want to i will give a shout out
if you're interested in historical
things i just spent a whole bunch of
time writing a bunch of this uh the
history of the making of the my new kind
of science book
which is kind of a a little bit of a of
a um
well it's sort of interesting
perhaps
for understanding a little bit about
uh how
ideas progress but it's also really a
bit of a scroll down a memory lane of
the technology of actually producing
documents
and
a deep dive
into
the adventures of printing a book very
high resolution
um and
some of the things that can go wrong
and i leave it if you uh haven't read it
yet i'm not going to uh uh
do a spoiler here let's just say there
are adventures that um uh we encountered
in the production of the book which you
can read about that
all right thanks very much and